we'll be about another operation yes so
like the previous talk this talk is
going to be about a combination of
research work and applications that came
out of an NSF frontier effort that is in
its fifth year in the Greater Boston
area so in some sense this is like the
same talk as last time right but with
one big difference that my title does
not include the word privacy anywhere in
it and that's on purpose so unlike the
last talk in pretty much every other
talk of this workshop this is not
actually a talk on differential privacy
so if you're a differential privacy
aficionado and you were hoping that
every single talk in the workshop would
be about this then I apologize on the
other hand if you're truly a
differential privacy aficionado you're
used to not having perfect accuracy so
this is sort of the noise I guess so
okay so my talk is called a modular
approach to cloud security I will
describe what most of these words mean
throughout the talk presumably you've
heard of the word security before but
don't at least I have no idea exactly
what this word security means but I'll
describe to you at least what we're
doing in this project let me start with
the one word that I guess most of us
might might be familiar with which is
cloud right so cloud computing or other
people's computers are is is is a very
nice innovation over the past decade of
sort of giving anybody in the world the
ability to store data and to make it
available for anybody else in the world
to use to to spin up elastic
computations to do very very strong
number crunching at will from anywhere
in the world and at very low cost this
is a very cool idea
clouds are cool everybody likes having
cloud computing or even having a cloud
data center so even all of us at bu and
the Greater Boston area have a
production cloud environment that I'll
mention later in the talk
but for now what I want to talk about is
sort of what exactly underpins cloud
computing right so we have this very
nice vision that we can tell to sort of
freshmen or sophomores in
ses course about sort of you can just
sort of outsource your calculations to
the cloud but let's step back for a
minute and think about you know all of
the amazing computer science and
engineering innovation that went into
building this thing that we sort of take
for granted now right so so we have all
this complicated morass of software of
hardware and of networking that makes
all of this possible right so just to
give a simple application I could build
you know a web application running on a
single machine in the cloud that you
know can can can connect to a web
browser that runs on top of an operating
system that runs on top of some sort of
commodity hardware that is connected to
all the other machines in the cloud and
the rest of the internet via a network
and that's just like one machine out of
the millions of them on the cloud and
furthermore everything that I just said
in the previous sentence can all be
virtualized at pretty much every single
level of the computing stack so it's
kind of a minor miracle that all of us
were able to as a computer science and
engineering community build something
this complicated and the key innovation
that that I want to argue that made all
of this possible is the idea of
modularity right so that there's no one
person in the world that could describe
to you how any sufficiently complicated
computer system works that all of us
sort of work at different levels of
abstraction so I might be an operating
system expert and I know how to build it
and I don't need to care about how you
know the details of how all the computer
programs that run on top of me are going
what are they gonna do and I don't
necessarily need to care too much about
how the hardware underneath me works as
long as it satisfies a certain number of
basic principles and everything is all
good right in the same of all the other
levels of the cloud and but this isn't a
talk about how to build a cloud this is
a talk about cloud security so the
question is sort of how can we secure
something this complicated and the short
answer to this question is that we know
how to sort of provide some small like
we can we can sort of prove things of
the former or makes very strong
defensible claims of the form you know
widget a in a complicated competing
architecture has security property B or
at least can't be broken by attacks of
type C so I can show how you know
different operating systems could be
secured against side-channel attacks re
against like attacks from
different privilege escalation attacks
will not work against certain
applications running on top of the OS
where I can prove to you that a piece of
hardware is sufficiently safe from
side-channel attacks etc etc but how do
I even know that all of these pieces if
I can even individually prove that they
are secure whatever even this words this
nebulous word secure means how do I know
that in something sufficiently
complicated like a cloud or any other
sufficiently complicated computing
architecture that the composition of
individual protocols gives us security
of the overall cloud right so modularity
was the key to making the correctness of
the system working if all the individual
pieces work correctly then the system
composes nicely and the question that is
sort of at the the underpinnings of our
of our project is does the same process
work for security and the answer to this
question is no if you take a bunch of
components that are individually proved
to be secure for again for most notions
of the word secure I'm leaving this word
vague for the moment that just because
you take a bunch of components that
individually seem like they're doing
their job fine they could destructively
interfere with one another and if
multiple components are running on your
computer at the same time there could be
some bug that exploits the
interconnections between two processes
that in some sort of stand-alone sandbox
environment either one of them would
have been fine okay so the goal of our
of our frontier project called the
modular approach to cloud security is
sort of to resolve this ambiguity and
sort of as a pun that Ron Kennedy came
up with is you know to build security
systems that so rather than having the
sum of the parts be a whole it's instead
like a holistic security guarantee okay
so this is a project involving a large
number of researchers across four
institutions of U MIT Northeastern and
the University of Connecticut and I
can't describe all of the work done by
all of these people so I'll give a small
subset of the stuff that we're trying to
accomplish and I'll you know a big
caveat up front that the work that I'm
going to describe is is is definitely
biased towards the stuff that I myself
am doing just because I'm the one of the
group giving the talk and therefore I
get to bias it towards myself that's my
right so I'm doing that
okay so there are two components that I
want to sort of two different halves to
my talk first I want to talk to you
about how we're doing work into building
composable security analyses so so
analyzing the security of various
computing services in such a way that
those analyses continue to hold even as
each individual widget fits into part of
a bigger ecosystem and the second thing
I want to describe which is very
different is talking about a unique
computing environment that we have in in
the Boston area called the Massachusetts
open cloud and how that can enable some
cool new secure secure computing
applications okay
so begin with the first part of
composable security analyses and so what
we want in this project is to sort of
move away from a monolithic computing
environment that we sort of get with any
commercial cloud provider today you know
Amazon Google Microsoft whatever in
which everybody sort of you know when
you sign up to any one of those systems
everybody has sort of you know the
ability to use the same exact kinds of
software you have one of a relatively
small number of images you can run and
all the back-end cloud software is all
whatever the you know the the company
that gives you the cloud like that rents
you the computer say Amazon or whoever
also manages all the software that that
that underlies how the cloud works and
everybody must trust that company once
and forever and everybody gets the exact
same kind of you know isolation
guarantees from all the other than all
the other tenants on the cloud and so on
and so what we want to do is move
towards a world that sort of maybe maybe
more economics driven in the sense of
every single tenant can sort of freely
decide and flexibly change their
decisions as to what kinds of pieces of
hardware and software on the cloud they
choose to trust how much they're
concerned about the correctness of what
about the timeliness or performance
efficiency of results how much they're
concerned about the privacy of their
data and the isolation of their
computing processes and finally to
connect all of these together the cost
that they're willing to pay and where
they want to apportion their actual
dollars when they pay for the first
services on the cloud in which which of
these features that they want more
okay the the fundamental cryptographic
tool that underlies our our project is
something called universally composable
or you see security that I'll describe
next
so you see security is a way of arguing
that it's a way of sort of formalizing
this what I've called now since now
vaguely this notion of security in terms
of how do I know that a particular
algorithm or application or computer
program does what I want it to do so the
way that the one can codify security in
the in the in the language of you see is
to say take any you know application or
a computer program or algorithm any way
take any so take any application or
computer program in blue and the hope in
in the way that this security definition
works is that we can design some kind of
specification that is hopefully much
simpler and cleaner to understand than
the underlying program but that from the
perspective of the rest of the world
from anybody looking at this program
from the outside the program in the
specification are indistinguishable so
the spec even though it's hopefully much
simpler to understand and reason about
them this complicated computer program
that these two things are sort of
functionally equivalent at least as far
as the rest of the world is concerned
and so we'll say that a computer program
is secure at least up to specification s
if this thing is the case so so at least
as far as how its input-output behavior
works but this definition is a little
bit too rigid at least at the moment are
too weak at least at the moment this
sort of what I have described is not so
much a security guarantee but a
correctness guarantee right just that
the specification and the program are
functionally equivalent this is sort of
the domain of formal verification this
is what those like the the programming
language's community tries to do that
they try to say can i form some sort of
spec in some higher-level language that
codifies you know a c program or
something and that i can prove that
these are functionally equivalent but in
security we don't just care about the
sort of i/o behavior the input-output
guarantees but we also are worried about
you know what are the other
ramifications of using a system what are
the sort of
side effects that might spill out into
the world as a result of me using this
particular computer program it could be
the case that you know if this thing is
a piece of hardware that it could be
leaking side channel information like
timing or power analysis if this is a
piece of software
it could be reviewing it could be
interacting with other things in the
world and from looking at the
transcripts of what it communicates with
the rest of the world you could learn
information from it so the the real
notion of you see doesn't just consider
input-output behavior it also considers
these kinds of side effects and forces
them to be part of your modeling process
so your hope is that your complicated
computer program is represented by this
specification both in the way that it
interacts with the rest of the world
both in terms of how the rest of the
world sees it from from an input/output
semantics and in terms of any side
effects it spews out into the world okay
so you want to prove that these two
things are close so actually you don't
want to prove that they're identical you
want to prove that the hope is that the
specification is simpler to understand
than the program so you hope that
there's some sort of translation
mechanism or a simulator in the crypto
parlance that can translate between them
and so this is how how we'll define
security in the notion in the language
of Universal composability that's some
complicated program is is is is somehow
it is as secure as if we use some sort
of simpler to understand specification
if they're functionally equivalent P and
s are function equivalent and there's
some way to translate from all of the
side effects that you see in the real
world into all of the side effects that
you see in the specification and so the
hope is that the specification is some
simpler representation of the program
and so this was like a super quick
description of this complicated notion
of Universal composability if you're
interested in seeing more information
about it we have several hours of
lectures by Ron that we've recorded and
put on YouTube okay so in this in this
project this modular approach to cloud
security project are one of our big
objectives has been to prove the UC
security of many different components at
many different levels of the computing
stacks so we've proved the UC security
of method of
of cryptographic methods to do database
searches over encrypted data various
things involving block chains how to do
oblivious computing which I'll spend
more time discussing how to do anonymous
messaging so that you can route messages
over a network so that nobody knows
who's talking to whom and protect smart
contracts again over the in the
cryptocurrency space how to argue about
the security of different operating
systems especially a unit kernel-based
operating system that we've built at BU
that I'll describe a little bit later
how to understand and reason about the
security guarantees offered by different
pieces of hardware such as trusted
hardware and claves and finally how to
understand how the networking and the
cloud underpinning infrastructure that
that connects all the machines together
works including this open source program
called OpenStack that I'll describe a
little bit later and so we have all
these widgets that sort of specify how
these various kinds of applications work
and so we have specifications
corresponding to some of these programs
and the specifications you should think
of as a as a simpler way to understand
what are the ramifications of using this
program and the specification basically
includes a white list of any kind of
security defect or imperfection that any
one of these programs has or any kind of
prerequisite required to use it so for
instance if you have a mechanism for
protecting data using encryption one
prerequisite is that there has to be
somewhere to store the the cryptographic
key material right and the security of
the of the of the higher-level database
system depends upon that and so it's
relying upon some other mechanism
somewhere lower deeper in the stack to
to enforce that precondition and the
reason the main reason the benefit of of
proving all of these systems secure in
this universal composability way is that
then we can connect them together so
then we can do some kind of
mix-and-match system to say you know now
if you're a cloud tenant and you want a
system that I want to pay no more than X
dollars and I want to make sure my data
is confidential then there may be
multiple ways that you might want to go
about doing it in the hope of having
some sort of unified framework in which
to reason about what all of these
widgets
do and do not provide is so that then
you can make a sort of a comparative
analysis and an informed comparative
analysis as to how you want to spend
your computing dollars so just to give
one example of what I mean by this so
let me say a little bit more about this
idea of oblivious computing what I mean
by this is that there's some cloud
tenant C who has some complicated tasks
that it wants to outsource to a powerful
server on the cloud and the tenant wants
the cloud to compute this function for
her without learning this input X and
there are many ways that you could go
about trying to figure out how to you
know that you could go about trying to
build a system that will obliviously
compute the answer to this function in
such a way that the server has sort of
no idea what it's doing so so one
example is to use a cryptographic idea
called secure multi-party computation
which I'll describe in much more detail
later in the talk but the the punchline
here is that it has some trust
assumption that you split the
information over multiple different
machines and you trust that they do not
collude and as long as the different
machines don't aren't all working in
cahoots against you that the security of
your your data is protected as the
client there's a very different way of
protective doing this calculation over
protected data using trusted Hardware
systems like Intel SGX where the trust
assumption then is very different you
trust that the chip sort of does the
isolation that Intel says it does and
there's an even different method that I
guess maybe we don't think about as much
but it's probably the most much more the
the most common way that we use the
cloud is that we're just trusting the
cloud vendor is isolating our machine on
the cloud from all the other machines
and in the cloud and then we can just
throw all of our data in the clear in
that particular virtual or physical
machine and and compute the data there
and then destroy the the machine
afterward and trust that the cloud will
isolate the the machine from us I
mentioned this example just to say that
these are sort of three applications or
three ways of instantiating the problem
of oblivious computing that work in very
different layers of the computing stack
and are designed by very different
people who don't even often talk to each
other but by rethinking about this from
the standpoint of like what tangible
problem are they solving in some sense
they're all solving the same problem and
if we can show that these are all
instantiation z' of the same ideal spec
but that have different kinds of trust
guarantees and expose that directly to
cloud tenants then we can allow them to
see here three different ways of solving
the same problem it doesn't matter to
you that they use different technologies
what matters to you is that you want to
pick which one you are willing to trust
which of these preconditions you're
willing to trust and also how much money
you're willing to pay for it so you want
to put trust in the forefront and we
also want to understand exactly how
these security analyses work over
complicated systems that involve
multiple different layers so I'll give
you an example of this so one of the
applications that we're we're working
hard to build in a cloud data center is
to kappa to build a system that allows
medical doctors to take fetal MRIs so if
you've ever taken an MRI before you know
that like there's one really important
thing that you have to do when an MRI is
taken of you which is to remain still
for a while because an MRI is basically
taking a bunch of pictures of you from
many different angles and so in order to
make sure that those pictures are
sensible to the doctors so basically
reconstruct sort of a 3d image from a
bunch of 2d pictures you remain still in
the machine for a while okay this is a
problem when doctors are trying to say
take the MRI of a fetus to try to see if
there's any kind of medical
abnormalities in the fetus because try
as you might defeat us will not stay
still for you right like this is just
not going to happen so instead if you
want to take a bunch of 2d pictures
using an MRI of a fetus and try to
reconstruct them into a model this has
become a much much more complicated
computer graphics question of how to
take all these different pictures and
fit them together and almost no
hospitals have like the the computing
capability in order to run this kind of
computers sophisticated computer
graphics and so what they do is they
like they send it all out to other
people to do this for them and then they
get the results back in a couple days
but what we want to do is to make it so
that you know when when when a doctor
wants to take this this this fetal MRI
and combine it and form a 3d
reconstruction of the fetus that they
can do so by just buying a bunch of
computers on the cloud row renting I
should say computers on the cloud and
and spinning up a bunch of these induced
and this massively parallel izybelle
computation really quickly but to do so
right just to understand the security of
this very very privacy sensitive
information medical data about a fetus
requires understanding the security also
the security implications of all of the
things in the cloud that underpin it
right the operating systems you use and
the cloud management infrastructure
itself and whatnot and and all of these
pieces I won't belabor the details of
how these pieces work but they all sort
of have sub widgets of their own all of
these pieces so OpenStack is an
open-source system that most that that a
lot of cloud vendors use to orchestrate
running the the cloud itself it's about
nine million lines of code it's this
very complicated system that has many
many pieces within it and sub-sub pieces
and we've gone through the process of
trying to understand sort of in this
Universal composability framework how to
reason about the security of these
open-source systems like OpenStack and
yeah we have a paper about that which
was you know it took a lot of effort it
was like about a hundred page paper or
something like this and from this proper
procedure we've learned that the using
Universal composability
to prove the security of all these
complex computing programs is possible
but is really really tedious and we
learned a lot of lessons from this and
now we've started to go to the
programming languages community to try
to mechanize the active of formally
verifying the the security of computer
programs using using this tool called
easy crypt which allows us to prove in
you see security that a computer program
meets the specification both in
correctness and in terms of making sure
we've light listed all of the possible
security defects
we've completed a case study of this
that should be posted online very soon
so yeah so through this process the the
main thing that we've done in this in
this program is to to build these
composable widget these security
analyses of all these different widgets
so that we can compose them but there's
another thing that we've been working on
sort of it on a different angle within
this project which is based on our
collaboration with an organization
called the Massachusetts open cloud and
so but I'll describe then the second
half of this talk what this organization
is but first let me tell you the problem
that we've been trying to solve together
with them and the problem is to do
secure computing on the cloud so to give
some examples of why one might want to
do this these are some actual things
that we've talked about with people so
so there are companies in Boston who
want to compute the average salary to
understand that the pay disparity
between men and women or across
ethnicities but without exposing salary
data of any individual company or
researchers in hospitals who want to
understand sort of four diseases what is
an average case of a particular disease
X look like what are the the markers of
a particular disease the disease is
rather prevalent then the hospital has
enough data from its own patients in
order to understand this particular
disease but if a disease is rare that no
individual Hospital has enough data to
understand what is an average or typical
case of a sufficiently rare disease and
as soon as you want to talk about data
sharing across hospitals then we entered
the domain of privacy laws like HIPAA
that we've heard about earlier today and
so the question is how do you do so how
do you come up with this like average
case of a rare disease without reviewing
individual patient data or just this
sort of the generic version of this you
know companies want to run some kind of
data analytics in a public cloud but
they don't trust a single cloud provider
and the solution to this that I want to
talk about in the remaining part of this
talk is something called secure
multi-party computation and the upshot
of the way that it's going to work is
that rather than outsourcing any company
outsourcing its data to one public cloud
provider it's going to outsource it to
two or more okay so at first glance this
sounds worse right if you weren't
willing to outsource it to one cloud
provider why would you give it to
multiple cloud providers
and the answer is that you know we're
not going to outsource the company's own
data but we're gonna outsource some sort
of encoded version of the data will
encode the data across multiple cloud
providers in such a way that the data is
individually or even small subsets of
the data of the encoded data is
meaningless for understanding exactly
what the input information was but that
the cloud vendors can can can work and
can calculate over the data together to
learn some kind of analytic ok so I feel
like most of the talks here have had
either a definition slide or some kind
of legal statement so I figured I would
like you know fill out my bingo card in
one slide and combine the two so here's
like a picture from an actual
congressional bill in the last Congress
115 Congress it's a it's a bill called
the student right to know before you go
it would have for since most of us are
in the educational space the bill is
about educational data data about
students and using trying to calculate
interesting metrics from from data about
students like what are the average
salaries of future graduates based on
which university they go to and which
major they go to there's all sorts of
interesting data privacy questions here
but I don't want to talk about the bill
so much as I want to talk about this one
part of the bill which describes this
technology that the bill requires for
use when calculating these kinds of
educational statistics which is secure
multi-party computation so the
definition says the term secure
multi-party computation means a
computerized system that enables
different computing different
participating entities and participation
of private datasets to link and
aggregate their datasets for the purpose
of performing these pre-approved
computations without transferring or
otherwise reviewing this private data to
each other or anyone else so what this
means is you know we have a bunch of
computing entities these can be
individuals or companies entities that
hold their own data sets and they want
to calculate some function they want to
jointly calculate some function of this
data but they want to do so in such a
way without actually handing over their
data to each other ok so they want to do
it as if they were somehow handing all
of their data to some trusted blackbox
entity that would just sort of be a sync
of their data and that would compute the
function over their data that they
wanted and
and the function result back to these
participants and no more information
would be revealed so they don't have
this you know fancy a sinkhole black box
so they want to somehow compute this
function working with each other in such
a way that they learn no more
information than they would have if they
had this box okay so they just want to
learn a particular function of their
data and nothing else I'll emphasize
that secure multi-party computation this
definition says nothing about inference
it says nothing about whether this
function is something that they should
want to compute with each other or
something that would reveal too much
that the result of the calculation would
reveal too much in of their sensitive
inputs so in this way you know MPC is
sort of independent of but very
complementary and synergistic with
differential privacy so you can imagine
computing securely this any kind of
differentially private metric the MPC is
about protecting the act of doing the
computation over data held by different
parties and making sure that that
computation can be done in such a way
that nobody has to share their input
data with anybody else and the
differential privacy is about protecting
the results right so these are these are
sort of independent and synergistic
questions but for this talk I'm only
gonna like I said this is not a talk on
differential privacy it's I'm only going
to talk about the MPC piece and so this
idea of MPC of like sort of computing
jointly over data that we cannot read
and we don't have to share is something
that has been used in practice and a
handful of occasions I'll just specify
to that we've worked on but there are
others in addition to our own work one
thing that we've worked on is actually
calculating this this pay disparity
metric though at the wage gap between
men and women throughout the city of
Boston the most recent calculation we
did in 2017 involved real salary data
from about 167 thousand employees in the
Greater Boston area or about one in
every six employees throughout the city
of Boston the results of this metric of
sort of what is the overall citywide pay
disparity those reports are available on
the city of Boston website the
underlying data of you know what are the
individual employee and employer
salaries nobody knows because that's the
whole point of the system so we can
calculate the overall aggregate wage gap
without knowing anybody's individual
wage
another system we've worked on with a
nonprofit entity called Callisto
inspired by the the me to movement idea
is to build a system that allows
survivors of sexual assault and violence
to report their experiences in such a
way that the information is
cryptographically protected and
unavailable for anybody to read even the
service providing the server providing
this service unless another a lesson
until another person names the same
perpetrator this is based on the idea
that people might feel more comfortable
coming forward and making sexual assault
- accusations if they have if there's
somebody else coming forward at the same
time with them so if leaving aside the
social failures that lead to the fact
that one has to feel like this that the
point of the platform is to make it so
that the information this very sensitive
information is cryptographically
inaccessible to anybody until two people
come forward and name the same
perpetrator okay so so I've named two
different applications of this idea of
computing protecting data even while
you're computing over it there are a
handful of other ones that I won't I
want to describe in this talk but the
fact that I can more or less enumerate
all of the applications of MPC is kind
of weird this is a 35 plus year old
technology it seems like something that
could be very useful right we protect
data at rest all the time and in transit
but we don't protect data while
computing very often and and it's a
reasonable question to ask why one
answer you might hear often is the
performance of this system that it's
very slow and this is somewhat true but
it's changing very rapidly so secure
multi-party computation even over the
past half decade has gotten markedly
faster for decently good settings and
set in the sense of computing some
reasonably not too complicated
calculation in this case the Advanced
Encryption standard a yes over a
reasonably small scale data with a
reasonably ideal network is something
that can be done within this is a log
scale graph nowadays it can be done
within like an order of magnitude of
computing over data and the clear so
performance of MPC is not usually the
reason why why MPC is a big impediment
to use but it's at least on small scale
and and relatively simple calculations
so NPC has this interesting property but
you get sort of security of your data
from the fact that the multiple servers
that are communicating with each other
are isolated that they're all physically
distinct that there's no single attacker
who can control all of them but you get
performance from colocation of your
information this is because when you do
MPC you've sort of fundamentally traded
off computing for networking so so you
want to do some sort of joint
computation amongst these participants
but in order to do so you have to send a
bunch of information to to amongst
yourselves the information is encoded in
unintelligible but you have to send a
lot of it and as a result you've sort of
traded off in order to do any sort of
computation at sufficient scale you need
a lot of network communication and so
the faster you can do that network
communication the better that you'll be
and here's what comes into play this
cool system that a sort of a sister
project that we work with called the
Massachusetts open cloud the moc is a
production cloud environment it's out in
western Massachusetts and unlike most
cloud providers which are controlled
entirely by a single provider the moc
has multiple different entities that
build it so it's a single data center
into which anybody can go and rack and
stack a bunch of computers and and and
and manage them so there are many
different commercial providers that we
work with including Dell and Lenovo and
HP and Cisco and brocade and Intel and
so on and so forth and many of them have
a bunch of computers wrapped in stack
right so you have and they're physically
and different within the same data
center but in different parts of the
data center like with like fences
separating their own individual computer
stack so right so you have computers
administered by different people by
mutually distrusting and competitors
companies but that are in the same
physical data center so you have really
really fast network connectivity really
high speed bandwidth between mutually
distrusting machines which is exactly
the right environment in which to run
MPC so we get both the performance and
the security and yeah so so we've we've
spent a lot of effort as a security kit
as as a cryptographic community to build
MPC to scale which and
we can make em PC run pretty fast in
terms of the complexity of the analysis
that we do we can handle in principle
any computation but in practice
reasonably complex ones we can even
handle them with a reasonably large
number of parties there's a lot of
security a lot of crypto research into
that but data size is not usually
something people think about you know
usually we think about trying to run
complicated analysis over small-scale
data but the the distributed systems
community has sort of gone in the exact
opposite direction nowadays right they
do a lot of work that's reasonably
simple analyses over large scale data
and so what we wanted to do with this
project with is to make it easy for
software ordinary software developers
who work in distributed systems to make
it so that they can implement secure
multi-party computation and run it over
our multi provider cloud and so we have
this system called Conclave that does
this we call it Conclave it's sort of
like a secure Enclave but rather than
outsourcing your data to one entity it's
sort of outsourcing it to a bunch of
people who work together in order to
calculate whatever question you want and
so we have software available online and
a paper and the way that the basically
that the system works is that it allows
anybody to accept to input queries in
any like an ordinary sequel format and
it will run it on any existing data
back-end that you have like SPARC and it
will use any MPC engine that you have
available to run it and it uses a bunch
of fun bunch of static analysis tricks
to try to figure out how did can it
minimize the amount of data that it has
to process using secure multi-party
computation while maintaining the
security of the system so just to give a
simple example of let me skip ahead here
of how a system might work suppose
somebody has a calculation that they
want to calculate a metric over many
many different people's inputs data and
the metric as a sequel query sort of
looks like this it has some concatenate
operations and projects and sums and so
on the way that the system works it uses
a bunch of tricks to figure out how it
can optimize this query so for instance
it can notice that the first two
operations in this particular query are
catenation and a projection and those
two operations are commutative you can
do them in either order and they're the
same thing so you can sort of switch the
order of the projection and the
concatenation and the reason this is
useful is that then every single entity
can project do the projection the first
part of this query on their own so this
sort of box here represents the stuff
that needs to be done using secure
multi-party computation and now we've
kicked out some of the work from needing
to be done there we'll just ask each of
the people who hold input data to do it
locally themselves the same thing is
true of a concatenation and a sum and so
on and so forth so so now we can like do
even less work inside of the secure
multi-party computation at the beginning
and also at the end the final step that
I had here is some sort of division by a
constant and that's a bijection so
whatever you would learn from viewing
the output here you would learn exactly
the same thing from from the input to
that particular operator and as a result
it also can be done in the clear so it's
a tool that basically just automates
running like this process of sort of
figuring out how can it minimize the
amount of work that it needs to be done
and under secure multi-party computation
so we have this conclave software you
can the the package is available on
github we've also integrated in with the
the Massachusetts open cloud and also
with the dataverse system that you heard
about on the last talk which is one of
the largest repositories of social
science data on the web to make it so
that anybody can ask a query of
information held in dataverse even to
make a query over data that you maybe
don't have the ability to read in the
clear yes so in summary I've described a
few distinct efforts within our max
project first that this idea of
universal composable universally
composable security has that we've
pursued what can lead to modular
security analysis of different widgets
of the computing of throughout the
computing stack that can be composed to
understand how complex systems work and
that it is capable of being formally
mechanized and verified a second that if
we have this this unique infrastructure
this Massachusetts open cloud it's this
nice combination of sort of isolated
machines but very physically close
okay dude close to each other so we can
do very fast secure multi-party
computation and we have this software
package called Conclave that has this
some neat static analysis trick to
automate like sort of decisions of how
to make the MPC software run as fast as
possible if you're interested in the
stuff that I mentioned I'll just give a
plug and if you're the kind of person
who just likes to hop from workshop to
workshop we're running a workshop next
week at BU to look at sort of these
questions of secure multi-party
computation how to make it fast and
usable and formally verified
[Applause]
so the right so easy crypt itself is a
length is is is a package that allows
you to prove in principle you can prove
sort of any cryptographic most
cryptographic statements and it can be
formally verified with a very small
trusted computing base which is cool the
the it was not built to handle this
definition of Universal composability
and shoehorning it shoehorning you see
into easy crypt was a giant mess is the
technical answer and so so to prove the
security so what our case study was to
prove the security of just sending like
a you know a secure message
communication system like just to send
messages based on the fact that we have
like a key exchange mechanism so sort of
to impose the fact that you have like
difficult get a nor der to do secure
message communication you know a pen and
paper proof would take I don't know a
couple of pages the the easy crypt code
was seventeen thousand lines of code
which is not at all feasible but we
learned from this that a lot of the
reason that this thing was very big was
that there's a few things that ez crypt
sort of struggles with or is not used to
and it takes a lot of work to shoehorn
in but this worked it like there are
these very specific kinds of tricks that
we had to apply over and over and over
again so we think that this is
automatable
it comes from sort of the impedance
mismatch between the way you see works
in the way that easy crypt is like built
to handle but we think this impedance
mismatch is something that we can
overcome and that we're gonna work
towards sort of because like yeah we
just had to apply a few simple ish
tricks over and over and over again and
so we think that this process itself is
automatable so if we can build some sort
of higher level abstraction that can
then compile it down to this seventeen
thousand lines of easy crypt code on its
own we think that this is possible it
does it is a tactics based thing but
it's meant for not easily no no it's not
easily extensible
yeah when you were present in the
principle of universal compost ability
you are talking that okay
this notion candy will side Chinese as
well and then you show all these which
have different layers of construction
and connected them and so on and I could
think about a lot of site China's my
appear because of the interaction of
these components have you captured some
of these side channels in easy clip as
well and you know maybe if you can give
me an intuition like how hard would that
was if you did it of which side channels
do you considered right so so the this
let me first answered the part about
easy [ __ ] no this side channel like the
the easy [ __ ] work is is was a simple
case study so it wasn't nearly as
complicated as the pen and paper proofs
that I mentioned earlier the the side
channels that we refer to or mostly like
the the kinds of information that are
revealed in the act of doing the
computing so what kinds of network
communications are you exchanging so for
instance if you interact with a
particular website and it gives you a
token and that token is used to
authenticate you or or to authorize a
particular decision to be made then who
else has the ability to see this token
where did it flow across the internet
and who else might then be able to use
that to impersonate you that's an
example of a kind of thing that I mean
by side channel so I'm using the term
much more generally than just like like
power timing analysis kinds of things
right just sort of any information that
you see throughout the course of doing
the calculation that might potentially
be useful to an adversary at a later
point in time this is my my general
notion of side channel for example when
you were using this principle yes in in
some of the analyses yes yes this is the
nice time secure you put it together and
it's just
to be right so the system right so the
the universal composability comes with a
composition guarantee the composition
guarantee does not say that you know no
matter what else is happening in the
world that your system will be perfectly
safe because that's something else that
is happening in the world could be that
there's somebody out there in the world
that's spilling all your secrets right
maybe you gave your secret keys to your
best friend and something else happening
out there in the world is your best
friend is you know posting it on the
Internet
right so what it means is that you can
easily reason about how the systems
continue to play nicely together or not
how they constructively or destructively
interfere when they're composed it
doesn't mean that definitely everything
is okay it means that you can understand
how the program's the complicated
programs interact just by understanding
how the simpler specifications interact
if you look at how the specifications
interact if they interact nicely
together then you know the programs will
Elsie won't yeah
[Applause]